we teach you God's and grandmas ways of
handling money common sense when you
handle money using these basic
principles and you do it over an
extended period of time you will see an
inordinate level of success in good
times and in bad times whether there are
horrible things like storms that are
bearing down on us everywhere literally
or figuratively or whatever else happens
we teach you to live on a budget a
written plan jesus said don't build a
tower without first counting the cost
lest you get halfway up and you're
unable to finish and all you see you
begin to mock you and say this man began
to build and wasn't I unable to finish
if you manage money for a company called
you incorporated and you manage money
for you incorporated the way you manage
money for you now would you fire you if
the answer is yes then please don't pray
and ask God to bless you with more money
if you're miss handling it
scripture is real clear he's not going
to send money to someone who's miss
handling if you read the parable the
talents it's not it's kind of AI elates
common sense so you know you're not
gonna have a sudden financial windfall
that saves your life when you are
disorganized and undoing a budget not
living on plan when you start living a
plan you're gonna that diligence you're
gonna see things change you need to save
money for emergencies to buy things so
you don't go in debt when you buy them
and to invest and change your family
tree and send your kid to college you
got to save money you have to do it
every month and systematically and
intentionally it doesn't just occur no
one wakes up and goes I have a million
dollars Wow I wonder how that happened
it's like no one wins the Super Bowl
goes whoa how did that happen no it's
years and years and years and years and
years and years and years and years and
years and years and years and years of
diligence and throwing a football and
then you you win the Super Bowl maybe
but if you do no one you don't know they
never interviewed somebody after the
Super Bowl is over and they go I have no
idea it's just an accident
I was just driving along the car and now
here I am the quarterback of the winning
team I had
what's gonna happen no one does that
it's an intentional act over a long
period of time a series of habits and
processes and practices that get you a
shot at maybe being in the big leagues
right same things true with money save
money save money no one accidentally
changes their family tree and you know
you need to avoid debt the borrower
slave to the lender when you don't have
any payments you know what you've got
money I'm amazed at the number of people
that think that they're intelligent and
sophisticated that walk around the car
lease and credit cards and car payments
and they borrowed money for their
freakin vacation lame-o they can't even
afford to go out to eat and pay for it
lame-o I mean really absolutely crazy
out there and these are people that are
sometimes well educated but stupid I'm
one of those I don't got a good
education but I was stupid you can do
that it's possible you you you've met
well-educated stupid people before
haven't you I have some of my professors
I mean it's just nuts out there you know
and and you know you need to learn to be
unbelievably generous God loves a
cheerful Giver
people aren't generous they very seldom
win with money
very seldom win with money there's all
these other things don't you know don't
put your all your investments in one
basket
spread your portions to seven yes to
eight for disaster may come upon the
land says in Ecclesiastes that means
diversify don't put all your money in
one company or one stock or one thing or
one bank because you're asking for it
spread it around risk goes down when you
spread it around money's like manure it
grows things when it's spread around
left in one pile it stinks it works
don't be co-signing co-sign if you're
not gonna go in debt why are you
co-signing for a broke person to go in
debt little Johnny needs car I'm I help
little Johnny you think it's helping him
to get him in debt both of you
were dumb little Johnny needs a house
everybody needs a house I'm gonna cosign
for my kid to get a house you're stupid
you know I know this it says it in the
Bible says you're stupid
proverbs 1718 it says in the
contemporary English version the CEV
version of scriptures poverty 1718 says
one who cosines for another stupid
that's what it says in the Bible now if
you want to read one of the softer
versions you could read like the New
King James it says one lacking incense
signs for another you want do all the
versions we can do them but we don't
need to right now the point is it's dumb
to cosign when you cosign you're stupid
because the bank who loves to loan money
more than dogs like food I mean the bank
who very existence is to loan people
money and get them into debt doesn't
want to loan this goober money but
you're so stinkin smart you say goober
needs a loan and so I'm gonna sign up
with old goober here and hope goober
pays listen if goober was gonna pay the
bank would already loaned him money but
now you you are the goober cuz you get
to pay goobers payments and it's your
grandson on his truck or it's your
daughter on her house and you thought
you were being a blessing and you
weren't you were cursing them you were
getting them into debt they couldn't
afford to do new data coming out friend
of mine sent me this email this morning
a company called atom data studies
mortgage trends 23% of all mortgages
taken out last year had a co maker on
them a co-borrower on them one-fourth
Wow
that's a whole list of stupid now the
conclusion of The Economist in this
study of this data was that that means
that all those people are getting
co-signers because housing is so
expensive that poor little Johnny
millennial can't buy a house with that
is that it helping and that's just
really not the case
because here's the actual data okay cuz
I actually do this for a living of this
is what I do
co-signing is a lot of this but it's
Edco making loans meaning it's not a
husband and wife but I don't know if you
know this piece of information or not
but statistically more people live
together in America that aren't married
then live together that army
today and so this trend of CO borrowing
it what this is is you people that are
shacking up with your shack up partner
you're both signing on the loan and
that's showing up in this data now
that's also stupid because when you
break up and you get a divorce and
you're married the judge will dictate
how this mortgages handled when he just
decides he don't pay it anymore and
leaves baby you got the loan or vice
versa
so you don't have a marriage of what's
called a partnership and business and
law and it's a general partnership which
means if one of you doesn't pay the
other one's fully liable and so he goes
bankrupt darling you're left with the
whole bag of cookies because you're
stupid and you signed up for a house or
somebody you're not married to that's
stupid
it's gonna cost you get your head taken
off so if you want to buy a house and
somebody live with you you just buy the
house and live with them if you don't do
that that's the only way to do it I'm
not recommending that as a Christian but
aside from that legally and morally mean
legally and financially you're
straight-up stupid to be signing loans
with people to buy a house unless you're
married there you go see that's how you
win you learn stuff like this this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]